vw hat in diese skandal vorsätzlich
sittenwidrig gehandelt hieß es heute
das heißt die wolfsburger müssen bei
einer klage grundsätzlich schadenersatz
zahlen wie jetzt zugeschaltet auto bild
vize robin hornig robin was genau
bedeutet dieses urteil jetzt für alle
volkswagen kunden also für kunden die
vom diesel skandal betroffen sind
bedeutet dieses urteil vom bgh heute
eben eine richtig gute nachricht man
muss sich das konkret angucken
der kläger hat hierfür seinen volkswagen
den er 2014 gebraucht gekauft hat 28.000
euro zurückbekommen von volkswagen oder
bekommt ihr dann eben von volkswagen
zurückgibt sein fahrzeug zurück er hat
das fahrzeug ursprünglich gekauft für
31.500 euro also diese differenz von
3000 euro kommt dann dadurch zustande
dass er eben ein nutzungsentgelt zahlen
muss für 50.000 kilometer die er mit dem
fahrzeug gefahren ist aber unterm strich
hat er damit daneben noch einen sehr
guten preis für dieses fahrzeug erzielt
und darauf können jetzt eben auch andere
vw kunden die vom riesenskandal
betroffen sind hoffen können also alle
vw diese kunden jetzt eigentlich das
geld zurück verlangt für ihr auto nein
also man spricht aktuell von 60.000
anhängenden klagen wichtig ist dass bei
diesen kläger nur dass bei den klagen
eben klar sein muss man muss das auto
gekauft haben bevor der diesel skandal
2015 bekannt wurde
und da hat man schon ein bisschen
probleme den 10.000 dieser kläger haben
wahrscheinlich das auto da haben das
auto nach bekanntwerden des skandals
gekauft wichtig ist auch dass man
spezifische motoren voraussetzungen hat
also der motor der hier betroffen ist
das ist ein diesel der heißt 189 dieser
motoren typ muss dann eben auch
betroffen sein als es müssen
verschiedene faktoren zusammenkommen
dass ich dann eben als kläger jetzt eben
von diesem gerichtsurteil profitieren
kann
vielen dank robin hornig